I think we're ready. I'm getting thumbs up.
So I would like to thank the organizers for allowing us to
present the work
of
my lab, which is, I'm Ivan Topisirovic.
I come from McGill University
from Canada, and here we have Professor Larsson
and Ruggiero, who come from Karolinska Institute and
UCSF respectively. And I would like to thank the
organizers for giving us the opportunity, because we've been working on this for
quite a bit, which is how mRNA translation is dysregulated in
cancer.
And again, this session is going to be, when we say translation, is going to be
mostly from mRNA to the protein, not from the bench to the bedside, so I hope
people just won't get up now and leave. It happens.
But we'll try to convince you that translation is a very important process, and as
you all know, it's a fundamental process
that plays a major role in regulation of gene expression,
whereby
mRNA translation decides what the composition of the
proteome is going to be in the cells, pretty much as much as
transcription, although this has been
historically sort of lesser-knowledged.
And in addition,
protein synthesis or mRNA translation is also highly
energy-consuming process. So you can imagine that a cancer
cell that's frequently exposed to the lack of nutrients and
oxygen, so it's hard for it to make energy,
needs to somehow figure out a way to make enough protein, enough
biomass to support neoplastic growth.
And thus, it's not surprising that
translation is dysregulated in cancer.
As a matter of fact, the first
evidence for this comes 130 years ago from
Giuseppe Pianezzi's observation that malignant cells can be
distinguished, the non-malignant cells, by having this hypertrophic
and irregularly shaped nuclei, and that's because they make more
ribosomes in general than the normal cells to support making this
biomass to fuel neoplastic growth.
And today, we know that
most of the tumor suppressors, such as PTEN and p53, and
oncogenes such as Myc and KRAS,
actually impinge on translational machinery and directly or
indirectly
perturb the translatome in order to establish malignant
proteomes.
And in addition to this role in making more biomass,
now we also know that translation can be selectively regulated,
and this is going to be the major
sort of
theme here between three of our talks.
And this is achieved through interactions of the motifs or
features that are found in mRNA molecules, as
well as
trans factors, including translation factors as well as RNA
binding proteins and some auxiliary factors.
And the complexity here is enormous, which provides cells with the
sufficient flexibility to survive and adapt to stress,
which of course is relevant to cancer.
And
the reason for this is that all the mRNAs in the
cell need to compete for limiting amounts of translational
machinery, and based on these features, as
is presented in this graph that's taken from Gene Graphs Review,
some of them are very good in being
translated, so they're very good in getting to translational machinery, and
they're called strong
mRNAs, or designed here as strong mRNAs, and they happen to encode
proteins that have
housekeeping functions, and they are the ones that are
translated in most of the non-transformed cells.
Evolution, somehow, we're still not
sure how,
made it as such that mRNAs that are needed to
support neoplastic growth are more weak than these
mRNAs because their features actually
impede efficient translation, so the strong mRNAs
can actually out-compete them from the translational machinery.
And to this end, cancer cells need to increase the availability of
translational machinery in order to support translation of these weak
mRNAs that you can see here encode all these
tumor-promoting proteins. And this, as you can see
here, gives you sufficient therapeutic window
whereby you can restrict the availability of translational
machinery and selectively affect synthesis of
oncogenic proteins while not affecting the
synthesis of housekeeping proteins, which allows
selective eradication of cancer cells in preclinical models.
Professor Ruggiero here will talk about
these type of things. So without any further ado,
we have three talks today. I'll start by talking about translational
rheostat that we recently discovered that we think drives cancer
metastasis.
Then Olle Larsson from Karolinska Institute
will talk about how elongation is regulated through
modifications of tRNAs and codon composition of
the mRNAs. And then finally, Professor Ruggiero is going to tell us
about how drug tolerance in cancer is linked to this
selective protein synthesis.
So then without any further ado,
I will get into, see I don't know how to do this, to my
talk.
It's stuck on the...
I can give a chalk talk. Ah, there you go. Thank you. Thank you very much.
I must have pressed something wrong.
So,
I'm going to be talking about this recent discovery of ours where
we believe
thatTranslation
is dynamically regulated throughout the tumor evolution to allow tumor
cells to metastasize.
And I have
nothing to disclose when it comes
to this research. And I will start by acknowledging the people in the lab that
actually do the work that I so ungratefully take credit for.
And what we're interested in the lab and what's linked to
processes such as metastasis is how cells adapt to stress.
And as we all know, cells sense their environment.
This leads to activation of signaling pathways, leading to
perturbations in the proteome and metabolome, which if optimal, will allow cells to
adapt and survive,
and if not, this will lead to triggering
of some sort of cell death, elimination of these
cells.
So one of the major ways how protein synthesis is
linked to the surrounding environment of the cell is mediated
through the mechanistic target of rapamycin complex one,
signaling pathway. And this kinase
is a central sensor of the changes in the
environment, including nutrients, oxygen, energy status in the
cell, and so on. And based on that, it
stimulates anabolic processes such as lipid synthesis and protein
synthesis that we're going to talk about, and inhibits catabolic
processes such as autophagy. So,
under conditions when cells are deprived of nutrients,
oxygen, or where energy status of the cells is unfavorable,
the family of the small translational inhibitors that are called
4E binding proteins, that you can see here in green, and in mammals, there are
three of them, one, two, and three,
bind to the cytosolic cap binding protein,
called eIF4E. Once you stimulate the cells with
nutrients or oxygen or if the energy status
recovers,
mTORC1 is activated. This leads to phosphorylation of 4E-BPs that
inactivates them, leading to their dissociation from the
eIF4E,
thus allowing the assembly of the eIF4F complex and recruitment of
the mRNA to the ribosome. And this is a pretty well-understood
process that is
dysregulated in many of cancers because mTORC1 is
upregulated in almost all the malignancies.
So it's not surprising that eIF4E promotes
malignant transformation and tumor growth, and this has been shown by
Nahum Sonenberg first in the 1990 cell lines, and then here
with the present professor
Ruggiero, who showed this in vivo.
So if you have more eIF4E, cells become malignant, and these tumors
grow faster.
So
when Fedja Jovanovic came to the lab,
we had a student before him, Sophie, who decided that she wants to go to
medical school, so she said she wanted a project that's relatively
simple and straightforward.
And the project was to show that 4E-BPs will
basically act as tumor suppressors, which was known, but that they will
also
suppress metastasis,
which was expected because it was thought that eIF4E
promotes metastasis. So if you have an oncogene, the inhibitor of the
oncogene should block both primary tumor growth and metastasis.
And we teamed with
Ursina Sigler and Lee Marie Post ви's lab, and also Pasha
Woronov's lab, and Gio Mattia here in Pasha's lab, did a lot of work
here.
So, as I said, the project was supposed to be quite simple, and the idea
was if we cross the 4E-BP knockout mice with
polyoma middle T breast cancer,
polyoma middle T mouse that's a standardly used breast cancer model,
we expected to get larger tumors, and that
happened, but we also expected to get more metastasis, which actually
didn't happen at all. And there was almost no metastasis there, which was
highly surprising.
We thought that if you get rid of something that's a tumor suppressor,
metastasis should go up, not down, right?
And then,
of course, the first thing we thought of, that something inadvertent happened in
this
4E-BP1, two double knockout mice, or their crosses with polyoma middle T.
And to check whether this is the case, Fedja
reexpressed 4E-BP1 in this 4E-BP1 and two
double knockout cells, as you can see here,
and this was sufficient to recover metastatic potential of the cells.
So it became sort of apparent at this point that 4E-BP1 is
likely to stimulate metastasis rather to prevent it, although it
prevents primary tumor growth, or it slows down primary tumor growth, I should
say.
So then the question, of course, was, was this
cancer cells themselves or something within
the tumor niche or microenvironment?
And for that,
we did a very simple experiment where we took the wild-type cells and put them
in wild-type or a 4E-BP double knockout mice.
And there, there was no difference in metastasis, thus indicating that the observed
phenotypes are cell-autonomous, so that there is something in
cancer cells that prevents them from metastasizing if they don't
express 4E-BP1.
And
interestingly, so
this didn't work if you would constitutively activate 4E-BP1 and make it
stuck to eIF4E, which we did here with this 4Alanine mutant, where all the
mTORC1 sites are mutated to alanine, so this mutant is constitutively active
and bound,
to eIF4E no matter what mTORC1 activity is.
And here you can see that the wild type was much better in
recovering the metastasis in the lungs than the
4Alanine mutant, thus indicating, or at least
suggestingThat mTOR signaling needs to
tune 4E-BP1,
rather than just 4E-BP1 being constitutively activated, and this
starts
making us think about this kind of rheostat model.
But before we got there, we needed to sort of
dissect which step of metastatic cascade
4E-BP1 plays a major role in.
And I won't dwell on this because this is familiar to most
of you, but there is a number of steps that cancer cells need to
go through and overcome a variety of challenges in order
to disseminate to these distant tissues
and develop
metastasis.
So
we start looking at the steps in
metastatic cascades where
metastatic cascade with 4E-BP1 could act.
And first,
it was decided that we should maybe check whether the outgrowth of the
tumor cells in the metastatic site is affected.
For this, we use the tail vein injections.
So this way, you sort of surpass all the early steps in
metastatic cascade, and you inject a lot of cells in the tail vein of the mouse.
They colonize the lungs. And then
we
quantify the number of metastases.
And as you can see here, there was not much difference there, thus indicating that
4E-BP1 doesn't play a major role in metastatic outgrowth.
In turn,
we observed differences in invasion and
anoikis resistance. Anoikis is a program cell death
mechanism that's triggered upon detachment of the cells.
And these are two very early steps in metastasis.
And you can see that 4E-BP1 status in the cells
was a determinant there, whereby the cells that were
4E-BP1 proficient invaded more, and they were
also, as you can see here,
more resistant to anoikis, as you
can see here. And also importantly, you can see that
mTOR signaling under the conditions of detachment,
which is here,
is reduced, as you can see, by phosphorylation of these downstream substrates
of mTORC1.
So we decided then to see what the mechanism here could
be. And to do so, we compared the
transcript and wide changes in translation, that are also known
as translatome,
between the attached and detached cells that are either
4E-BP1 deficient or proficient. And this led
us to another surprise. So not only that 4E-BP1,
that it didn't make much sense that 4E-BP1 as tumor
suppressor is increasing the number of metastases or is actually
required for metastasis. 4E-BP1 is also a translational
suppressor, but we could see actually translational upregulation
of a number of mRNAs, most of which were involved in
the processes that are actually implicated in the early steps of
metastasis, such as migration, invasion, and anoikis
resistance. And one of those was pannexin 1,
that plays a major role in the matrix cell contacts
and interactions through ATP and calcium signaling.
So Pedja went to test what else could be
there, and here it was observed that
mRNAs that the translation upregulated upon detachment
in 4E-BP1 proficient cells, so those whose translation is
4E-BP1 dependent,
and their synthesis is upregulated,
actually have much longer five prime UTRs,
as you can see here. And they also have a
higher proportion of upstream open reading frames that are relatively
well-established
translational control elements in their five prime untranslated
regions.
So this led us to think that these features of the mRNAs
somehow make these
transcripts translation upregulated under conditions
where 4E-BP is actually activated and translation should be
inhibited.
And then it was decided that we should validate pannexin
1, and you can see that the protein levels of pannexin 1 are
upregulated in the cells that are 4E-BP1 proficient compared
to those that lack 4E-BP1. There are two
bands here because there is a cleavage product that's recognized with these
antibodies, so they're both
originating from pannexin. And there was no change in the RNA
levels of pannexin, thus further suggesting that this
increase in pannexin 1 protein levels is indeed occurring at the level
of mRNA translation. And then if you deplete
pannexin 1, this invasive advantage of
cells that are 4E-BP1 proficient was actually diminished,
whereas pannexin 1 didn't have that much effect on the cells that didn't
express 4E-BP1. So this indicated that
4E-BP1,
pannexin axis is involved in stimulation of these early
steps
or stimulation of progression of cells through the early steps of metastatic
cascade.
But we still couldn't understand what's going on and why
4LN mutant that's constitutively active didn't work better than the
wild type.
And this led us to think about this rheostat model.
But it's easy to think, it's much harder to prove, but Pedja
is excellent. So he came up with this experiment
whereby he would sort of dosemTOR
signaling by stimulating cells with serum and then monitoring what
happens to pannexin-1 protein levels.
And you can see here when he starts adding serum,
that pannexin-1 peaks before mTOR signaling
is maximally activated, thus indicating that
this translational increase in pannexin-1
requires
not too much,
but a little bit of mTOR signaling, some
sort of a Goldilocks zone, if you will, and so on.
When you continue stimulating cells with serum and further induce mTOR
signaling,
the pannexin-1 levels go down, and then if you inhibit
mTOR signaling by this mTORc1-specific inhibitor,
pannexin-1 is reduced again.
And then he did a similar experiment with mTOR inhibitors, where he just dosed the
levels of mTOR inhibitors, and he observed the same thing.
In this concentration gradient, there was a dose of
mTORc1 that induced pannexin-1, and before and after,
the levels of pannexin-1 were lower.
So, this led us also to think that
just inhibiting mTORc1 may not stimulate metastasis, which
would be
sort of advantageous considering that some of these drugs are in the clinic.
And indeed, that happens if you put mTOR inhibitors and
inhibit mTORc1 almost completely.
So strong inhibition of mTORc1
sort of decreased the invasion potential of the 4E-BP1
proficient cells, as you can see here.
So this led us to this model whereby the stressors that
act across metastatic cascade, of which there are many,
tune mTORc1 activity to the point that the
translatomes are going to be remodeled in 4E-BP1-dependent manner in a way
that favors metastasis. And this also
allows cells to switch between proliferative and
metastatic proteomes, if you will,
because proliferation needs to stop in order for
cells to migrate, invade, and survive in oicus,
meaning survive in
the circulation. And then it needs to be reactivated once they
go to the secondary site and need to grow metastasis or secondary
tumors.
And we do think that this is a major
mechanism that's implicated in metastasis, and we think that this is
how protein synthesis is implicated in this process.
Of course, we still don't understand the precise mechanism.
Maybe I shouldn't have said, of course, but we don't understand the precise
mechanism of how these mRNAs, such
as the one encoding pannexin, are upregulated under these
conditions. But we are working on it.
And
in the sake of time, I won't get to this last point here.
It turns out, which was the third surprise in this project,
that these effects are specific to 4E-BP1 and not its
very close parallel, 4E-BP2, whereby it was thought that these two
proteins have completely redundant functions and can
substitute for each other.
But in conclusion,
I
would say that-- And this all come from Peija.
I did very little here. This was all driven by him.
He's an extraordinarily talented PhD student.
That although 4E-BP1s may be tumor suppressive when it comes
to primary tumors, they
stimulate metastasis,
so there is this kind of
antagonistic pleiotropism. You need 4E-BP1s
not to be very active when the primary tumor grows, but then you have to tune them
down
in order for cells to metastasize.
We think that this rheostat that's dialed by
mTORc1 and centered on 4E-BP1,
enables cells to switch from proliferative to metastatic states, and this
doesn't require any changes in
genomes of the cancer cells that would make them stuck in one or the other
state, but allows them to sort of exhibit enough
plasticity in order to move through metastatic cascade.
And finally, we think that this occurs by
upregulation, by paradoxical upregulation, I should say,
of the mRNAs
that's 4E-BP1 dependent. And with that,
I would like just to thank all the collaborators and the
people that gave us funding to do this
research. And I'm going to take questions, if any.
Thank you very much.
Nice work. So,
maybe I missed it, but did you see any changes in
translation of EMT markers?
Looking at epithelial-mesenchymal transition, like Twist and Snail and things like
that.
We've seen some.
I believe we've seen Nanog,
and we've seen one of the Hox genes, and
Sox2 as well.
Okay.
So they were also upregulated. But there's work before that shows that
actually inhibition of 4E-BP1
or, sorry, stimulation of 4E-BP through inhibition of
mTOR and activation of integrated stress response would actually favor translation
of such mRNAs that are involved in EMT.
But what we believe it's also that
a slight change in mTOR activity
could change this. So once the cells get to the secondary site, you
can turn off this program and activate the other program, right?
And then stochasticity and low efficiency of metastasis would come
from, I guess, the fact that mTOR signaling has to be at the right level
throughout this whole thing. Yes.
Yeah. And then also, it was sort of interesting because you saw an
increase in survival under anoikis conditions.
Yeah.
But then when you
injected these cells into the tail vein,
it seemed like they were surviving at the same rates.
Were you getting both like same number of nodules and same size or were
they changing?
We do, but tail vein is a bit of cheating because you put millions of cells
in. And then from the tail end to the lungs, they usually get there because they
travel as clumps and whatnot. So I think that
that's inherently, that anoikis is sort of overcome by the
model.
Yeah. Thank you. Thank you very much.
Yeah. Very nice work, Ivan. Congratulation.
I have two quick questions. Did you see any difference in the expression
of metalloprotease or
protein that are implicated in invasion?
The MMP3 was upregulated-
Okay
... in the 4EBP1 cells when they detached.
And concerning panexin,
I don't know it very well. Is there drugs that target this protein?
I think that there's some in development, but I don't think that any
of them are even close to the clinic because panexin is this strange thing that's
like panexin, but it doesn't align, so it doesn't make a channel.
So it's still debatable what panexin 1 in some ways does, but it does make
cells leak ATP and calcium, and because of that,
there's some indications in neurodegenerative diseases where I
think they're trying to make these inhibitors, but I think they're very far from.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Do you think it's possible you're switching from 4E-dependent to
4E-independent translation?
That's what we think, and we went after eIF3 and eF5 and all kinds of
things that were knocked down. I didn't have time to show, but can show later.
And it turns out that they don't affect this.
I think that somehow,
tuning the levels of 4F makes these RNAs more
translatable, which we don't understand.
And obviously, because the upstream open reading frames, we looked whether there's
any difference in the introduction of eIF2 phosphorylation integrated stress
response, but we couldn't see any differences between the two.
But it's still
the major headache that we're having. Yes.
That's why Pedja cannot graduate for the year now trying to figure this out.
Yes, last question, please. Oh. Okay.
If you're quick, you can do both.
Go.
So I'm not in the field, but I'm curious about this Goldilocks situation.
Do you know anything about it in terms of the intra-tumoral
distribution? If there is a population of cells that has low mTOR
activity, then another one that has high activity, meaning that one portion of the
tumor proliferates and the other one is more invasive.
We have a secondary goal here, which is to develop reporters that will detect
these metastatic cells very early.
So put them in a tumor and see which ones light up so we can isolate them
and answer this question. But I'm pretty sure, there's heterogeneity in mTOR
activity in the tumor for sure because some cells get more
nutrients than others, more oxygen, so yeah. For sure. Yeah.
Okay, last.
That was a great talk, actually. Congratulations.
I'm just curious that,
is there an overlapping role between EB1 and
2?
Just out of curiosity.
We thought that they're going to be redundant, so that's why we never did the
experiment with 4E-BP2. But then Pedja made a terrible mistake
and did the experiment with 4E-BP2.
So if you put back 4E-BP2, it's going to work exactly the same
as 4E-BP1 when it comes to tumor cell proliferation.
But when you put back 4E-BP2,
it has no effect on metastasis, so cells cannot metastasis at all.
So there is a difference, and now there's old work from
McCarty's group. Tuschka is, I think, first author, EMBO paper from
'97, I believe.
When the papers were still hard copies, you know what I mean?
And the editors were a bit better, I would say.
But the idea there was that there's slight
differences between certain motifs within
4E-BP1 and 2 that could explain maybe this way.
So we are trying to switch them as they did back in the day,
in this yeast reconstitute system, and we're hoping to find something
here. And again, I shouldn't take any congratulations for this work
because the only thing I was saying is that nothing makes sense, and Pedja should
really be congratulated and the other people in the lab.
And with that, thank you all. So next we have
Professor Ole Larsen, who decided to take his tag
off, but I know him. It's Ole Larsen there.
And he's going to be talking about the dicodon
organization and how it links the RNA modification to
cancer cell proteome. All yours.
Right. So thank you very much to the organizers for
the invitation to come here and present some of our work that
is
completely unpublished, so this is really new stuff.
So I have no disclosures.
So Ivan already showed you this
kind of figure that outlines the different steps of the gene expression
pathway. So what I would like to emphasize again is that each of these
mechanisms will, under certain conditions,
contribute to establishment of the proteome.
And we often talk about the translate, which is really the
sort of the subset of the mRNAs that are efficiently translated.
So when translation is regulated,
this has two effects. So one effect
you can think about is if you have different genes within the same
cells. So different genes, they will not produce necessarily the same number
of proteins per mRNA molecule. So this sort
of allows the translation process to control
relative protein production within a
cell.But what we more often talk about, and what
Ivan was also talking about, is the dynamic regulation, where you can
change the translation of individual mRNAs to tune
protein
levels.
And this happens then, for example, between different disease context, but
also, of course, during normal physiological responses.
Ivan was talking about translation initiation,
but usually you talk about three different steps
during and the translation process, where initiation involves the
association with ribosomes with the mRNA,
their scanning, and identification of the start
site. This is then followed by the elongation phase, when
the protein is synthesized, and
finally termination.
A key
molecule during the elongation phase is the tRNA, and
I would just like to remind you that most amino
acids can be decoded by
more than one tRNA.
So this means that you can actually generate identical
protein sequence with different codons.
So today, my focus will be on the elongation
process, but I'm also going to talk about how the
elongation process interacts with the initiation process.
So tRNAs, it's a fascinating molecule that I never thought I
would study, but I ended up studying it anyways.
And it's heavily modified, and these modifications, they affect the
stability of the tRNA, but also, for example, the
translational fidelity, and therefore, these modifications are
thought to have an important role in maintaining the dynamics
of the elongation process.
I'm going to focus on one
modification at the U34 position,
which occurs in a subset of tRNAs that
decode these codons, as you can see here.
This modification is mediated by
a pathway that I will refer to as the
ELP3 pathway.
And what you can see is that this leads to the addition of a
relatively bulky modification at this U34 position
here.
So we became interested in this by coincidence when
we saw that ELP3 is actually regulated
via estrogen receptor signaling.
So here you can see that depending on the activity of the estrogen
receptor, ELP3 protein level is increased
or decreased.
And this also leads to changes in these
modifications, as exemplified over here, where you can
see that treatment with fulvestrant decreases
the proportion of modified
tRNA at the U34 position within the cell.
So what we asked-- Of course, this is a complex
experimental system where when you stimulate with estradiol
to modulate
estrogen receptor alpha activity.
So we used a more simple model system where we just
changed
the-- So we asked what
this pathway more specifically does
in cancer
cells, and we focused on hormone-dependent cancers.
So
first of all, you can see here that in this cell line over here, which
is non-transformed, the expression of ELP3
is lower relative to these cancer cell lines.
And you can see that you can reduce the expression
using CRISPR methods, and that this results in, again, a
reduction, but not elimination of the modification at the
U34 position.
While this doesn't affect the proliferation in the
non-transformed cells,
it reduces
proliferation in the transformed cells.
And you can also see this in, for example, colony formation assays
or organoid models of the same
biology.
So we wanted to understand what this modification actually does
in this context. So to do this, we took cell
lines that either express ELP3 or not, and we
used a combination of proteomics and a method called polysome
profiling that you can use to profile translation.
So during polysome profiling, you collect mRNA that has
many ribosomes associated with them, and then you quantify
them. And then you can compare this to the total RNA level in the cell to
see if the translation has changed of these mRNAs.
So when we looked at protein levels, as expected, we could
identify a reduction of ELP3 and also many other
proteins. So then we used the polysome profiling
data to try to understand the mechanisms that underlies the
reduction in protein levels. So here is a plot where you
compare the total mRNA changes depending on
the ELP3 versus the levels of the translated
mRNA or the polysome-associated RNA.
The blue dots here are the mRNAs that encode the proteins that
were reduced, and as you can see, they are all, or
not all, but most of them are above this diagonal.
So what this means is that these mRNAs
actually have more ribosomes
associated with them than you would expect.
Nevertheless, they actually make less protein.
So this is consistent with a block of elongation.
If you compare it to the data that Ivan was showing-This
actually, if the regulation is at the level of initiation,
you actually expect to see more proteins if the--
So you can probably appreciate the complexity here.
So the idea why this happens is that if an
mRNA has codons with a high
requirement for these modified tRNAs, then
reduction of these modified tRNAs would lead to poor
elongation of these
mRNAs.
So we tested this simple hypothesis,
and here you can see
codon usage in proteins that were upregulated versus
those that were downregulated. And then for individual amino acids, you can
see that this codon here that
requires a U34 modified tRNA is
more commonly used in the proteins that were downregulated
versus those that were up. So we could have stopped here
essentially and said that we can explain the changes in
the proteome, depending on tRNA modification by simply these
codons. But the problem with this is that we don't really have a
quantitative measurement for this.
So we went on and used a method that
we developed in collaboration with Ivan and his
lab,
called PosNet. So what PosNet does is that it uses
many features in the RNA and tries to
quantify their individual contribution to the regulation, but
also how much of the regulation they actually explain.
So when we applied this, we noticed that when we
included these codons,
we could actually only explain 15% of the regulation.
And this is sort of illustrated here by this network that shows the
different
features of the RNA that contribute to the regulation and also
their sort of co-occurrences, because that's another problem when studying
these effects in translation. So
15%
was much less than we typically observe when we do this kind of modeling.
So it really suggested that there might be something different than
just simply the codon usage. And what we
thought was that maybe it is something in the
vicinity of the codons that also contributes
to the regulation. So the most simple thing you can think
of is actually a dicodon. So it's a combination of two
codons, and of course, there are many combinations, but they're easy to study.
So then we used another model here where we also introduced
dicodons, and what we could see was that with the dicodons,
we actually doubled the amount of regulation that we could
explain. And we identified the number of dicodons that both
associated with more protein and/or less
protein. Interestingly, in this model, we
can also look at how much each of the features that we
identify contribute to the regulation independently
of all the other features in the model.
So here, when you look at the single codons, you can see that they can actually not
explain anything independently of the other
features or almost nothing. This is in contrast to the
dicodons that seem to be better at independently
explaining the regulation.
Among the proteins that were
reduced, there were six dicodons, and
notably, they all have one codon that
requires a U34 modified tRNA
to be
translated.
When we looked at
the number of such dicodons, you could see that the more of
these six dicodons that you have, the more likely you
are to see reduced protein levels, but you can also see
that the effect seems to be relatively modest.
Nevertheless,
there are many of these
mRNAs that have multiple dicodons.
But interestingly, in contrast to just the
U34
codons that sort of
correlate with the length of the coding sequence, so if you have a longer coding
sequence, you will have more of these
single codons. The dicodons don't correspond to the length of the coding
sequence.
So therefore, we thought that maybe there is another factor here,
which is the distance between the dicodons.
And what we could see was that when we looked at those
mRNAs that had the dicodons closest, we could see a more
strong reduction in protein levels than those that had the
dicodons far apart.
And this is illustrated here. So actually this subset here, the
dicodons are very close. So they're only 18 nucleotides
apart, median. So this suggests that it's
not just the dicodons, it's really the context that they
are in.
And of course, when you look at this, you
realize that
although there is a sort of statistical difference here,
there's a lot of variation. So we thought that maybe these contexts can
help us to understand why some of the mRNAs here are more
affected than others.
So to do this, again, we used this modeling, but
we used the local sequence features, so meaning the features
that are around these dicodons. So interestingly,
we could of course find some features that
related to the
elongation process and features in the coding
sequence. But we also found many
features that were in the 5 prime UTR, which was kind of unexpected
because we were looking at
elongation.So we wondered,
does this mean that mRNAs that have these dicodons, do
they also have a sort of distinct translation initiation
activity? And what we could see was that the more
dicodons that an mRNA had, the
less efficient translation initiation it has.
So these mRNAs seem to be protected
against having too many ribosomes loaded on the mRNA at the
same time. And Ivan talked about the length of
the 5' UTR. Indeed, we could see that those mRNAs that
have several of these dicodons, they also had
longer 5' UTRs, which is typically associated with less efficient
translation.
When we look at the function of the
proteins that are encoded by mRNAs that have these dicodons, they are
really
enriched in cell cycle-related genes, and you can see that this
is conserved between human, mouse, and also yeast,
and notably,
many of them have to do with the mitotic
process. So therefore, we wondered whether the proliferative
phenotype we saw when we removed the
reduced expression of ELP3 was related to
mitotic defects. And indeed, you can see that in cells
lacking
ELP3, you can see a larger proportion of mitotic
defects. So this seems to confirm that
reduction of this tRNA modification lead to errors in the
elongation process that might really affect these kind of mRNAs.
Also, what is expected if you have an elongation
problem in the cell is that you would see ribosome
collisions more commonly, and this leads to activation
of the integrated stress response, which
includes both a global suppression of translation and also activation of
a set of genes that
act as
effectors during the stress response.
So we wondered whether this response was activated in
cells that could not modify tRNA as efficiently.
And indeed, as you can see here, as judged by the phosphorylation of
EF2alpha, as well as the expression of ATD4, indeed,
cells that lack ELP3 expression, they have activated
integrated stress response.
So we wonder whether this would also then affect the phenotype that we saw, but
surprisingly,
instead of showing increased expression of the genes that
are in this translational signature, we actually saw
reduced levels of the corresponding proteins.
It was highly unexpected, and we could see that
they seem to show the same type of pattern as we observed
initially, meaning that they actually seem to be blocked in
elongation.
So they had higher association with polysomes, but you didn't see
the same effect at the level of the protein.
And we think we can explain this by the fact that they
also have higher frequencies of these
dicodons. So this would position
tRNA-dependent regulation
upstream,
that this will determine the protein output also during the
integrated stress response.
To look at this in more detail,
we took two genes
and asked whether
these patches where we see these dicodons could
explain their distinct regulation patterns.
So we had one gene here, STIC2, both of
these showed reduced protein levels.
This in presence of increased polysome association, and
TMT6 didn't show this. So here we would expect an
elongation effect, and here we did not.
We took different regions from these genes,
a region containing the dicodons, and then
a controlled region that was, in this case, just
upstream, and in this case, it was a bit downstream to avoid
having other features here that might affect translation.
What we could see was that these
mRNAs, despite showing very different modes of
regulation, they had similar
frequencies of
codons that require U34 modified tRNAs.
So the
single codon usage was very similar despite having these
differences in
dicodon usage.
To do this, we took these sequences here
and cloned them in between two reporters.
So when you express this, if this sequence in the
region here
suppresses elongation, you will see less of the mCherry
reporter relative to GFP. And indeed, for the
gene where we expected an elongation effect, we saw a dramatic
reduction in mCherry expression, but this was not the case
for the gene where we saw this
pattern that suggests regulation via mRNA levels.
Moreover, when we
expressed these cells in cells with or without ELP3,
we could see that ELP3 modulated the mCherry
expression for the STIC2
gene,
and this
dicodon region, but not the control region.
So this leads us to propose a model that
combines translation efficiency with
elongation efficiency, here exemplified by ELP3.
So the elongation effectIn this model will only
happen when initiation efficiency is high,
but elongation efficiency is low.
So we think that this might explain the selectivity of cancer
cells, because typically cancer cells have elevated
initiation, and therefore, they probably have a higher requirement
for efficient elongation.
So with that, I would like to thank the people who did the work, Jana,
and also I would like to emphasize that this is a collaboration with
Luke Fuerix's lab, who's sitting right there.
And if you're interested, there is a bioRxiv manuscript available.
Thank you.
Questions?
I guess I can ask one. So when you say elongation, do you know
whether this is in--
What translon is it? Is it in upstream open reading frames of these genes, or is it
in the major coding sequence of the genes? How to distinguish between these two?
I guess we know that they have more than
three ribosomes associated with them.
But of course, if they were all in the upstream, we wouldn't know.
But on the other hand, when we take these reporters,
we can sort of reproduce the effect.
So at least for these genes where we did it, it's not.
Right. You know it's good.
Yes. Fascinating
work.
I saw that you worked on prostate cancer cell lines.
So did you look at the expression of ELP1 in
cancer patients,
of your protein in cancer patients versus...
There are some. ELP1, I don't know, but ELP3.
Yeah. Three, sorry.
Yeah. There are some studies, and it's in
certain cancers, yes, it's increased.
In prostate cancer, I have to admit, I don't remember.
Okay.
Yes. In breast, yes.
Okay. Thank you.
Let's see. Online, there's no. Okay, let's then thank Dr. Larsson.
And last but not the least, we have
Dr. Davide Ruggiero,
who's going to tell us how selective translation affects drug tolerance in
cancers.
All right. So thank you for sticking around.
Thank you, Van, for organizing this
exciting meeting.
So my lab has been interested for a long time in understanding how
post-transcriptional regulation really shape the proteome, either in
health and disease and specifically in the cancer context.
Today, I'll tell you actually an unpublished story about the
importance of translation selectivity in the
early steps of drug tolerance.
So these are my disclosure because I told you that I'm showing
you all unpublished data, so I appreciate no photo, no
posts or whatever you're taking.
So actually, I'm going to start with this slide.
That the slide actually is the unfortunately realization
that mRNA level is not a good
predictor of a protein abundance.
So I'm trying to tell you that already normal growing
cells, the mRNA level can predict only for around
40% of the proteome. What is more
important, interesting, and essential, especially for this
session, that even if you do an analysis on pan
cancers, it's an atlas of many cancers.
mRNA level can predict only almost
30% of the cancer proteome. So what
I'm trying to tell you that all the mRNA, single cell C, RNA,
whatever, it just tell you a little bit of
what the cancer proteome is actually shaped.
And what I'm saying is that the post-transcriptional
mechanism, specifically translation, we believe are critical
to really shape the cancer proteome in almost each
step of cancer evolution.
And this importance of translation control in the cancer
proteome, you already heard today two talks, is
even more important during stress.
You already heard it from a great talk of Ivan and all of that.
So think about cancer cells are the best survivor, right?
So they survive
low nutrient, hypoxia,
oxidative stress. We try to kill them.
The immune attack with therapy. No matter what,
they survive. They find a way to be
alive and carry on,
basically on making tumors. Now, why in this
context, the translation
bring a lot of benefits?
Here there are three bullet points. One, speed.
You can change the protein abundance when the mRNA is already
there in milliseconds, in seconds. Right?
Transcription takes much longer, hours and much longer, right?
So speed,
rapid response,
selectivity. You already heard so far
how translation is no one unit. It's always selectivity.
The cancer cells are instructed to say which mRNA need to
translate in time and space during their tumor evolution.
Three,
mRNA storage on demand. There are so many mRNA in the cytoplasm,
and they are not translated. They are there, boom, ready to go and to be translated
on demand to use specifically to this rapid response.
All right?
So all of this basically is extremely important.
As I said, if you think about the early steps
of drug tolerance, and today I'll tell you again, a completely
unpublished story.
It is in the context of breast cancer.
You already heard talk about the important transition control in breast
cancer.
So these are cells that are exposed to high
dose of hormone therapiesAnd there are some
population of the cells that started to be tolerant.
All right? So these cells has been given different names, persistent
cells, dormancy. We really didn't care so much
how to call. We really care about the mechanism, right?
In fact, actually
for our study, we call TSC for
therapy-surviving cancer cells. All right?
So now how the cells rapidly start to tolerate
some of this drug exposure. That's been associated with
change in epigenetic, change in metabolism, change in transcription.
But the truth is that still we don't know what is the cause by which the
cells start to become tolerant and eventually become
full resistance to drug therapy and carry on, on the tumor
evolution. All right? So that is our major question,
how these therapy surviving cells
basically tolerate acute stress, and how this process,
that is the key, right, can be druggable.
So one of the major point and a major problem of curing cancer is
actually drug resistance. And that is a point that for us is
very important to understand how translation control in this context can be
druggable.
So we did this in the context of a large subset of
breast cancer. This is like breast cancer associated with the deregulation of the
estrogen receptor alpha that account for almost
75% of breast cancer case. ER alpha, as you know,
is a transcription factor, bind estrogen, go in the
nucleus, increase the transcription of many mRNA important
for breast cancer, okay? And of course, as a
transcription factor, the ability to bind the estrogen, this has led to
actually different therapies. One is, of course, tamoxifen, is a
drug that compete with estrogen, bind ER alpha,
block ER alpha transcription activity, and this is still one of the
first line therapy for ER alpha positive breast cancer
patients. On the other side, there's also another
drugs that we also use in our context. It's called fulvestrant.
And fulvestrant actually still block ER alpha transcription activity, but
partially also degrade ER alpha. And this also is also used
as other first or second-line therapy, usually for patients
that become actually resistant to tamoxifen. So why I'm telling you this?
Because we use these two hormone therapies to, once again, to
understand how ER alpha positive
breast cancer tolerate high dose exposure to this
hormone therapy.
And this work is being done by an amazing talent
postdoc that is sitting here without the hat.
It's Ashish Norhan that really did all the work that actually I'm
showing you today.
So Ashish did basically, this is the flow through of the
experiment. So we used cells that were either naive to hormone
therapy, such as MCF7, T47D,
or cells that were already tamoxifen resistant,
MCF7-TAMR, or the cells that actually Ash
will give to us. These are cells where the ER alpha is mutated, and
all these are tamoxifen resistance.
So he cultured the cells, and what I'm showing you today, all the
experiment has been done upon the exposure and high
dose of fulvestrant for either 9 or 15 days.
Okay? And see after this time, which cells
remain in the dishes, either here or here, and
how the cells that actually once again started to
survive and tolerate to high exposure of fulvestrant,
what is the gene expression that account for their tolerance?
All right? So to do this, what we did,
these are again, MCF7-TAMR treated with fulvestrant,
not treated, means no TSC, or that one that remain on the dishes,
so the TSCs. And we did RNA-seq. We did
ribosome profiling in these cells.
You already heard what is ribosome profiling.
You assess translation efficiency and mass spec.
Now,
the cells are under high stress, right?
And indeed, you expect that there is some decrease in overall protein synthesis
that we see that. But the coolest thing that there were specific
mRNAs, that they were translationally
upregulated, and actually when we compare mass
spec with RNA-seq, we didn't see so much agreement.
We found better agreement between the translateome and the
proteomics. An interesting thing are this group
of mRNA that are translationally specifically
upregulating these TSC cells, and their protein abundance
by mass spec was also upregulated.
So when we did the GO term of this
gene, we were also very surprised to see this GO term categories,
because all of these are associated with things that are
studied more in neurobiology.
Calcium signal,
axon guidance, tight junction, CPGMP.
So we were really surprised, but in the same time interested, it's like
why early step of drug tolerance has
something to do with things related with neurobiologies.
And this was a little bit more clear when we found that one of the
best hits that is present in actually many of these GO
terms was CaMK2D.
So CaMK2D is a critical calcium calmodulin
kinase. It's activated by calcium and calmodulin.
It plays an important role to activate localized
translation during synaptic
activation and long-term memory.
So what I'm trying to tell you is that indeed, this is a process that
we know already that extremely important for
neuronal activation, this localized translation, because obviously this
has to occur in milliseconds.This is they cannot wait for
mRNA coming from millimeters away from the soma to arrive here.
CaMK2D plays an important role in this translation
regulation. So we really started to hypothesize that this
early step in drug tolerance really hijacks this
localized translation mechanism that usually is, in the normal
context, used in synaptic plasticity.
Now, we started to understand whether this was real in vivo.
And we use here two PDX ER alpha positive,
and we can see that upon treatment with fulvestrant, you see
CaMK2D nicely goes up and it goes up, we know at the
translation level, no transcription, no stability.
So that was actually real already in a more physiologic in vivo
breast cancer context.
Sorry, I go back. So obviously, we started to understand how we
can
block this calcium activation and see whether or
not it may have an effect in tumorigenesis or
this early step of drug tolerance.
So we thought actually to repurpose.
And drugs that actually you can buy very easily with a simple
prescription, and many people use this drug for lower blood
pressures. So this is called verapamil, I'll call vera.
That is actually is a blocking of an, calcium channel.
We thought, "Why we don't repurpose this for cancer for other
purpose?"
So first of all, we did an ex vivo system
where we use other verapamil or, for example, another calcium
chelator. And we already saw that in this context, we
reduce the number of TSC in culture.
So already we knew that these things was working.
But in vivo, we want to understand, can we really use this almost in a
preclinical setting? So we use again,
different PDX, again, the alpha positive.
And,
after we gave fulvestrant for almost 20
days, and then we stratify in three groups, the mice.
Mice that were first of all exposed for 20 days fulvestrant, and then
were carry on to give a fulvestrant.
One that was given only verapamil, and one was all together the
combination. And this was the cool result.
In fact, if you use with verapamil,
with use fulvestrant, as expected, you see a cytostatic effect of the
PDX. But after 45 days, if you keep going
to give fulvestrant, this tumor start to basically regrow.
With the idea that indeed here you reach for these tolerant cells, and
eventually this tumor carry on. As a single agent, verapamil
doesn't do much. But the coolest thing is in
combination, you see a beautiful effect.
So almost again in vivo showing that the increase
of these tolerant cells still relying on calcium
signaling, and can be used, this one, as actually therapy.
All right?
Now, another important aspect of cells that
start to become tolerant to drug is actually the
acquisition of metastasis. This is happening in many patients
that are right in the clinic after becoming resistant to hormone therapy and are
very bad breast cancer actually progression with
metastasis. So we try to understand,
and whether or not are the tolerant cells that actually we
characterize with the high social fulvestrant also acquire metastatic
potential. And what Ashish did,
did an amazing experiment where injecting the
heart, the no TSC or the TSC cells with
either CaMK2D or after he knocked down 6% of CaMK2D,
and check actually what happened in the metastasis,
and that experiment also give rise an exciting result.
The no TSC cells actually they don't do much metastasis.
But the coolest thing is our TSC cells, these tolerant cells start to
actually acquire metastatic potentials and go in the
site that actually are really relevant in patient samples,
liver or brain. So again, we are characterizing this
population of cells start to be tolerant to hormone therapy
and also acquire metastatic potential.
And the most important thing, that this metastatic potential is
directly functioning to CaMK2D expression, because when he knock
down CaMK2D, you really block completely metastasis.
Okay?
So after this, of course, the bigger question is about how in this
context, right? We
keep talking about translation specificity. That is the cool part.
How in this moment of drug
tolerance, the cells that high stress still
increase the translation of a specific mRNAs?
I diverge a little bit here. I want to get confused because I told you that ER
alpha is a transcription factor. Yes, it is.
But few years ago, actually, we discovered that ER alpha is also an RNA
binding protein. Bind the 3'UTR of
specific mRNAs,
and we also show that it's important this RNA binding
activity for tumorigenesis independent from its
transcription activity. In fact, this is only one
data that I'm showing you. This is a xenograft where we engineer RNA
binding mutant cells. So we mutated the RNA
binding domain, so we characterize the RNA binding domain, and then the
cells actually fail to form a tumor.
So obviously, our question here is, okay, ER alpha is also an
important RNA binding protein. How this plays a role in this
early step of drug tolerance? And how this is related, for example, to
CaMK2D?And we were very excited to find
that
ER alpha bind in beautiful size in the KMK2d 3'
UTR. This is an RNA clip that we already published.
We analyzed the data, and we were very excited that ER alpha directly bind
the 3' UTR of KMK2d. We also show that the
cells that now, where ER alpha can no longer bind RNA,
make less of these tolerant cells.
Again, showing that ER alpha RNA binding activity is
important for this drug tolerance step.
And we can rescue this defect if you overexpress
the KMK2d with alpha prime or 3' UTR.
So again, linking functionally the ER alpha RNA bind
activity with KMK2d.
Now, 3' UTR, it's an important regulatory element to the mRNA.
It's important for localization, stability, and we know that it's actually
important for translation. Often, it's important for translation because there is
an interaction between the 3' UTR and the 5' UTR that you already
heard today, how important for translation.
So we also ask, what happened in the 5' UTR of KMK2d?
And we did an analysis where we found that the 5'
UTR of KMK2d is enriched in sequence
or
specific polypurine or specific
putative G-quadruplex. All features that
make an mRNA to be translationally sensitive
to an RNA-like case, eIF4A, that you already heard
in the previous talk. Because all these features make
the 5' UTR very structured.
And usually these are, again, you heard already,
mRNA that are low translated normal cells.
Instead, the cancer cell love to have more of these
RNA cases for A to increase the translation of this mRNA.
So,
what I'm trying to tell you here, that the idea so far is that ER
alpha bind the 3' UTR of KMK2d. And we thought that,
again, eIF4A must be involved in the 5'
UTR on translating KMK2d. Believe it or
not, we went back to our previous data, and now
this is a cytoplasmic ER alpha interactome that we pulled down the ER
alpha from the cytoplasm. We did the mass spec.
ER alpha interacted with the few translation factor, and eIF4A was the
best. In fact, Ashish confirmed this by
IP. In other MCF7, and even there's a
stronger interaction between ER alpha and eIF4A in
MCF7 tamoxifen resistant. Again, with the idea that more cells start to
be drug resistant and tolerant, and this interaction, ER
alpha 4A is important. So of course, again, the idea
is that you need the 5' and the 3' UTR,
okay? To increase the translation of KMK2d in these
tolerant cells. And what Ashish did is another amazing
experiment where he engineered all these RNA
construct, where luciferase is flanked by the wild
type KMK2d 5' UTR, or the 3' UTR wild
type, or where he mutated the ER alpha binding site,
or where he revert the 3' UTR as a control.
And the coolest thing you can see here that only he transfected RNA,
and only in the tolerant cells you see a beautiful
increase in translation when you have 5' and 3' UTR.
So what I'm trying to tell you is that this really points to a picture that there
is a loop in mRNA. This is very well known to
increase the translation of mRNA between the 3' and the 5'
UTR. And two trans factor, ER alpha on the 3'
UTR, eIF4A on the 5' UTR help to loop this mRNA and
to increase the translation of this KMK2d in
the tolerant cells.
Now, why we were excited to see eIF4A involvement?
I told you already that the eIF4A is an oncogene.
I already told you that eIF4A is an oncogene because cancer cell
love to have 4A to increase the translation
of mRNA that have the structure. And we know that many mRNA that have
the structure are things that cancer cell love to increase
actually the translation. Because encode for
oncogene, survival factor, growth factor, all of these led
actually to the development of the first clinical inhibitor
for eIF4A. This is called zotatifin.
Is a molecular glue that actually glue eIF4A on the
specific polypurine on the 5' UTR of mRNA that are
also present in the KMK2d. And this zotatifin has been
already tested in different clinical trial, give some promising
actually result,
also in breast cancer. So we thought that, well, if this
drug tolerance phenotype rely on eIF4A, so this should
be also sensitive to zotatifin. That was our, of course,
important aspect to find drug ability of this step.
And the result, again, they're very, very positive.
We give zotatifin, we see less TSC cells.
An important thing that the decrease in TSC cell
number by zotatifin can be rescued by KMK2d
only with the coding sequence but not with the 5' UTR.
Linking indeed because of course with the 5' UTR, zotatifin still can block
the translation of this construct.
So this link at least in part the therapeutic
benefit of zotatifin on killing these tolerant cells
with the translation of KMK2d. But of course, how in vivo is
important. And we did the same series experiment in xenograft,
in PDX, already show you in the context of rapamycin, where we
pre-treated in this all context for 20 days cells
with fulvestrant to increase the tolerant number of the cells.
And then we stratified in three groups.
And here is interesting because now zotatifin alone in this
context as a single
agent already has an effect in blocking these
tumors. But nicely when you combine with
fulvestrant, you have a very strong tumor blockage,
especially in PDX or in xenograft.So we were very excited to
again develop, and we are actually bringing this to the clinic
to take zotatifin as a new point,
a new drug for, of course,
killing and breaking tolerance of breast cancer.
Last slide, we collaborate with Anna Bosch in Sweden.
We analyzed 400 ER alpha breast cancer patients.
And again, we were very excited to see that if you check mRNA
or KMK2D, it doesn't tell you anything.
KMK2D mRNA protein is completely discordance.
But there was a beautiful correlation between the KMK2D protein and the
EF4A protein. Again, sustaining and corroborating
also in patients that indeed this can be a key node
for increase in KMK2D and other mRNA in this early
step of drug tolerance. And then, of course, we saw that
increased KMK2D increase metastasis, and this is the most important
curve, where these are 400 patients stratified for low or
high KMK2D after hormone therapy.
And the patient that have high KMK2D did much worse compared to
what have a low KMK2D. So we're really excited to potentially use
this as a new biomarker and to understand how actually also
therapy can
be stratified in this context of all these patients.
The last slides,
just summarize. We really think that we are discovering that this
early step of tolerance cells hijack once
again a neuronal-like translation control.
This is used again to rapidly activate
neurons. We think that this is, again,
very provocative, but can be very important once again, even to think
about as a memory. We actually follow
thinking about whether this translational in this tolerant cells has
true translation activation as a neuron, as a memory
rememberer. You know what I mean? How the cells can be actually exposed
to drugs. We are very excited because we found that this can be
drugable with verapamil or with zotatifin.
And we also developing right now an inhibitor
for KMK2D kinase that can be even more, of course,
specialized to kill actually these cells. All right?
And this is the lab. I already
acknowledge Ashish, that has been really the driving
force. Many UCSF
collaborator, Anna, and many other people that actually helped to
develop throughout the years this
translation inhibitor that we already brought to the clinic.
Thanks for your attention.
Thank you, Davide. Questions for Davide?
Go ahead.
Hi, I'm Sandra Ortiz. I work at the Cancer Research Center in Lyon.
Great talk. Thank you so much. I was wondering whether you know if
there are specific characteristics of the sequences of the mRNAs that are
translated during drug persistence.
You show this looping between the five prime and three prime UTR,
but are there
sequence specific characteristics?
Yeah, no, it's a very good point. So I didn't show you for...
So actually, after we did the ribosome
profiling, so we checked the 5' UTR of
these genes that were upregulated.
So the first thing we saw, not only in KMK2D, but also in other
mRNA, this polypurine G-quadruplex.
So again, with the idea that obviously it's not only KMK2D can be a
target of zotatifin. In fact, actually, we also did the ribosome profiling
upon zotatifin, and there is a beautiful overlapping.
So that is the major thing that definitely was clear.
But we are still actually analyzing if there is something else related to, again,
E4E or some structure, right? But
all the sequence that are very well known to be associated with E4A
are one of the strongest, yeah.
Okay. And I was wondering whether if you do, I don't know, gene ontology of
these sequence specific modulators, whether they
belong to a particular pathway that
is related to survival or...
As I said, like you heard before. So in general, for example,
this sequence at this polypurine stretch, this possible
G-quadruplex, this structure. So we know very well that actually
many survival pathway oncogene
themself. We recently published a story on the
androgen receptor alpha. It actually has a
very huge complex 5' UTR, is actually sensitive
to zotatifin. Yeah, no, it makes sense, right?
Because these are sequence structure that restrain
increased translation in a very normal context.
The cancer cell need to be the opposite.
So that's why they love a lot of this RNA helicase.
Thank you so much.
Sure.
Elegant work.
I wonder if you can share your insights on the different effect
of Vera alone and Zota alone on the
tumor size
in your xenograft model.
Yeah, no, it's a good point. First of all, we didn't know if Vera was going to
work. Actually, we are very excited because as I said, it's very simple drugs.
So I think the Vera works better in combination because
if you keep going and give it for sessions, you keep basically
increasing these tolerant cells.
And the cells of the tumor start to become more and more,
basically addicted to calcium. And that's why Vera is going
to work, right? This in combination.
Zotatifin, again, and going back to the question that
addressed before, obviously target, for example, KMK2D, but I
already can tell you that target also other oncogenic mRNA in that
context.
Mm-hmm.
So that's why as a single agent is the strongest, right?
But also in combination, you saw the data is very, very
profound.
Thank you.
Sure.
Paul.
Do you know if the SERM resistant ER mutations, do they still
bind
the mRNA in your model?
Which resistance, sorry?
The SERM.
When you give resistance to SERMs, the ER gets mutated.
So do you know if the mutations are still capable of binding-
Oh, in the ER alpha you mean?
Yeah.
Yeah. Definitely still bind RNA.
The mutation bind RNAs. We already showed that, for example,
when the ER alpha in the cytoplasm, you give,
whatever, Tamoxifen or other
analog still bind RNA. So that actually to me makes
sense, because actually all these drugs in general kill the
transcription activity of ER alpha.
But we know the ER alpha is still important for breast cancer tumor even when you
become resistant. So how does this?
That's why I think the RNA binding activity translation will make
completely sense.
Beautiful story. Thanks for sharing.
I had a question about ER
alpha binding to EIF4A.
Sure.
I might have missed a little bit of the detail.
Could you elaborate on how ER alpha
increase or modulate the activity of EIF4A?
Yeah, I didn't show so much details. I only told you that bind directly.
ER alpha, EIF4A. Okay? And I show you,
we
found this actually before through a proteomics.
After we pulled down the ER alpha, we did this by IP.
And Ashish also basically did all
mutagenesis analysis where we know actually which
domain of ER alpha bind which domain of EIF4A.
So there is actually direct interaction. It's pretty cool.
Does it increase the protein expression of
EIF4A?
Oh, if increase the protein expression in EIF4A.
We didn't see much that.
Okay.
Although I remember
that actually years ago someone was published that ER
alpha is a transcription factor.
Mm-hmm.
Increase the transcription of a specific translation factor.
I don't remember if 4A was there.
But yeah, we don't know. It's also possible that it might be linked through
increase in transcription. Yeah.
So you think it's more likely it's the binding itself improves the-
Yeah. ER alpha bind directly EIF4A.
That's why these two proteins really
come together and increase this beautiful translation
specificity in this context. It's a protein-protein interaction.
Great. Thank you.
Sure.
All right. Thank you.
Thank you, everyone. And again, thanks
to the organizers that they organized this
session on protein synthesis that we all think three of us don't need convincing
to say that it should be within hallmarks of cancer and so on.
Okay. Thank you all very much.